cbs news senior business analyst jill
schlesinger joins us now for more about
the surging rate of inflation and the
rest of the nation's economic picture
jill good morning to you first question
you know where did we see the biggest
rise when you look at inflation as a
whole
well let's start with the places that we
encounter most frequently look at energy
energy costs up over 33 percent from a
year ago and of that energy component
gas prices are just soaring up nearly 60
percent from a year ago that's the
largest annual increase since the spring
of 1980.
then you go on to the grocery store
you're driving to the grocery store and
as you saw in that piece everything
costing more food costs up 6.1 percent
and again it's those proteins that are
really driving a lot of the rise in food
costs those costs are not going away
anytime soon one little glimmer of good
news was that services which usually
comprise about 60 percent of consumer
spending those costs are rising but not
nearly as quickly as all those commodity
prices
joe you mentioned those gas prices and
the high and looking back to 1980 how is
this different though than that raising
inflation that we saw in the late 70s
and early 80s
well it's very different because in that
time we had very slow economic growth
and right now we've got robust economic
growth part of the reason why this is
such an interesting time is that you
know we've been sort of a little bit uh
on pins and needles waiting for things
to actually get open and grow now
they're open and people are going out
and going crazy so the reality is that
right now this inflation it's not going
away anytime soon but it is important to
know the companies especially the
profitable ones they are starting to pay
their employees more so that should help
joe let me ask you about that timeline
the president says he believes inflation
has peaked do you believe that
well i don't think it has peaked yet and
i think that this is a econ 101 lesson
in spades when you have constrained
supply we do have that a lot of supply
shortages and surging demand we have
been waiting for almost two years to
spend some of the more than two trillion
dollars that we have amassed as
americans that combination is explosive
it's why we're seeing such high levels
of inflation it's likely to recede over
the next year but you know what we could
reset at a higher inflation rate than we
were before the pandemic before the
pandemic 2019 1.8 percent was the cpi
what we're probably looking at a year
from now two and a half maybe three
percent and that's something americans
are going to have to get used to
next week jill the federal reserve will
hold its last meeting of the year what
should we expect and why should people
be paying attention to this
well the federal reserve led by jerome
powell is going to change its monetary
policy and this is very important before
his congressional testimony jerome
powell had
originally said oh inflation is
transitory it's temporary now they've
shifted during that congressional
testimony powell said that the fed is
going to stop buying all the bonds it
was doing as an emergency measure and
that will pave the way for an increase
in short-term interest rates all of this
could happen sooner than previously
expected the fed will lay out its plans
next week and listen gang i know you
sort of have your eyes glazed over when
we talk about the federal reserve but
this impacts everything from your
savings rates to your credit card
interest charges to maybe being able to
borrow money for a small business so i
promise i'll cover it for you so you
don't have to pay attention but it's
really important
you are always covering it jill and for
that we do appreciate it thank you